we turn to the phone lines right now
love this man and uh
love his show love tony love everything
about them uh
joining us it's been a while uh just to
chop it up michael wilbon here on the
rich island show how are you michael
rich i'm good how are you i am hanging
in there uh
i'll give you the floor on what we saw
last night with the nets what did you
think what we saw
well you know it's so weird i mean
it's gonna i don't think anything that
they do will be enough
until the real time to judge them which
is the spring we got a lot of time
between now and then
um because look that's their proving
ground
we talked yesterday you mentioned tony
we talked yesterday about
tony said what will be enough for you
tonight
i said there won't be there's nothing
they can do tonight meaning last night
nothing because kyrie irving's already
hit
a shot to win a championship so he's
already done that
durant's already won two finals mvps
he's done that
harden's been in the finals hasn't done
it
but all three of them let's face it i
mean why are durant
and kyrie where they are anyway because
to some extent
they wanted to prove that they could win
a championship being
the person the guy because durant
joined a group that already won two
titles obviously kyrie was playing with
lebron and harden hasn't won
and so this is one of the things that
you know players talked very openly
about those guys going to brooklyn even
before it happened and that
they were saying this is what those guys
are saying
and i don't believe all those players
around the nba were making that up or
lying i don't believe that i believed
that
they felt that or heard that directly
from these three so
from the two from duran and kyrie so
what can they do
i mean i don't know they could win 20 in
a row
that i mean that that's the only regular
season thing rich
that i think is gonna overly impress
anybody
because there is either cynicism
skepticism
you know there's there's sort of okay
let's see what happens is the traveling
circus
and this is what they put together so
there's nothing they can do in the
regular season uh
to really distinguish themselves they're
gonna have to
but they've got to play themselves into
a place
where they are ready to hit the ground
running in late
and i guess that's why we're spending a
lot of time talking about the other
stuff
uh and and the other stuff is a void
that kyrie irving is filling
uh by his absence and then his um
his zoom uh
in his return that as i pointed out uh
makes jay cutler look like he's standing
you know like like he he's standing up
right like he's protecting the queen you
know i mean
so um what what are you where where do
you where do you stand on that subject
matter
i i i i don't i don't trust kylie irving
i don't i don't trust him there's no
reason to
he's done too many things to
go the opposite way of earning trust i
don't buy him
he's a great talent he is one of the
great
talents ever for doing what he does
which is handling the ball
but and his i have i have a number i was
telling you know you talk about this
stuff all the time
i think i was i was talking to our dear
friend charles barkley
at the beginning of this and i just said
i got a
i have a number i have an over under
number for kyrie irving
and it is 6.5 and that is the number
i think of assists he needs to average
to sort of demonstrate that he can do
something else
because when you are one of the great
ball handlers of all time he's on a
short list
he's on a short list with marovich and
isaiah thomas and allen iverson
he's a wizard yet
he averages fewer than six assists a
game for his career
i think it's 5.7 rich
and so as i i have this amazing fight
with my son
every night my 12 year old's favorite
player is kyrie irving
and i say you know what if he's the
greatest player of all time my son's
at 12 years old nice i said i'll tell
you what if you pass the ball
that little to your teammates they would
beat you down on the playground
because he's averaging 5.7 assists
for his career he's i think he's top
six once or twice that's
not that's pathetic james harden
when he's only doing it at the end of a
possession can average 11 or 12
in a game i mean right now
um nurkic is averaging is that i mean
jokic is averaging how many assists
again he's leading the league
that's seven feet tall you you can't you
cannot ignore teammates as or
or not not ignore it not incorporate
them as much as
kyrie fails to incorporate them and not
have eyebrows raised i even made i made
my son
read out loud the year by year assist
averages
of john stockton and they were
double that you know they were in magic
those got 12 and 13 and says okay i'm
not that's not who kyrie is i get that
he doesn't have to be there
but if he's going to have the ball in
his hands that much it ain't going to be
5.7
that's not going to work with with kevin
durant and james harden on your team
so i want to see that i want to know
what i want to see what happens when
they hit a speed bump or two
and the players in the league who are
not seduced by them
are thinking and saying privately at
least risk the same sorts of things
when you say not seduced by them that
that
despite their resumes and again you
you you expertly pointed out that that
you know that harden's the only one who
hasn't won a championship there
but you know kyrie did make a shot he
did he did make that shot and it was
very crucial
you know what a comeback that was but
his boston tenure was a complete washout
i mean
he yeah kyrie's a four kyrie is a full
well there's a lot of four letter words
in boston that aren't four letters but
kyrie is definitely one of them and uh
so i i
i think he's got something to prove um
the rest of the league he does he
clearly thinks he has something to prove
he does well i mean
okay so the question is you're saying
the rest of the league is looking at
them and saying that they're still
quite beatable and do you think colin
sexton improved it or what
a lot of guys i think i think the the
ones who are less
seduced by showmanship i mean i've
talked to a few guys this week
and their whole thing hey okay well
let's let's see what hap because you
know what happens
harden has been a dud in the spring
a complete dud he said how many chances
he have with houston with
with other great players and he really
didn't want to share the stage with
russell westbrook or chris paul i mean
let's face it i mean he he didn't want
to play with them otherwise he'd still
be playing with
one of them at least so
harden's been a dud the adult in the
room who's played
no matter what all the time and just put
playing
at the forefront regardless of what
people people can think whatever they
think about his level of sensitivity if
they think he's overly sensitive
or they think he shouldn't have joined
golden state all that's
that's the fodder for opinion kevin
durant will go out there and play even
if the result
is he's gonna have one leg to play on
we've seen him do it
kevin durant will risk everything you've
got just to play
kyrie irving yeah personal reasons
don't don't want to be there don't want
to play in memphis
don't want to play with out durant
so those two i i think that the the
skepticism is really directed at them
i i certainly have heard no skepticism
directly to kevin durant nor should they
be
so uh i guess then we'll put a button on
it after this last one
part of the reason why kyrie didn't play
you you believe or you're hearing is
because of the schedule and the fact
that durant wasn't
uh one of the many one of the many
reasons
one of the many and i i'm you know i'm
not gonna uh act like i've been an
investigative reporter on this
because it doesn't really matter rich we
know there
are he's got a stack of reasons as to
why he didn't play
i and i don't and listen one of them
could certainly sound more noble if you
are
emotionally distraught after what
happened on january 6 in the nation's
capital
but you think he was the only one right
i think it wasn't there weren't leagues
plural full of players
and staffers and coaches who were
distraught
but they found their way to the arena
um so i'm i'm not i'm not buying and we
saw this before with kyrie they didn't
want to play in the bubble
um it didn't want anybody else to play
so it's up to him to prove that he can
get out there because he just missed
seven games
and it wasn't you know the first x
number of those were not related to
anything
about a covet protocol
so you know people and it does it
doesn't matter really
what the excuse is um
he's got to prove he can do this because
the way he left boston
he left the team he doesn't have as much
talent as as this
brooklyn team but he left a team of guys
who can play
and they should have been deeper in the
playoffs you know with him and
they were actually better without him
michael wilbon here on the rich eisen
show
uh so who do you put your marker on in
this covet season
uh post mlk day who do you put your mark
on is it still the lakers then
for you yeah i think it is still the
lakers um
um i must admit just through these first
what is it 15 games i guess
the clippers have looked better than i
thought they would i thought the
clippers might take a backslide and
maybe they will i don't mean to
backslide
far like out of the out of the top eight
i don't mean that i just i could see
them in the middle of the pack or i
could
they're proving at this early point to
be
a little bit tougher than that um which
is probably a credit to tyron liu
but i i think i think you still have to
look at the lakers
um and say that
what slippage has there been you know uh
with that dynamic duo that none and so
yeah i would the east is what is
fascinating i mean the east hasn't been
this fascinating in a long time
in large part because of that traveling
circus i mean is brooklyn gonna what's
gonna happen when they play
against a couple of teams the sixers
who certainly should be better off going
into these playoffs than the bubble
than they were going in the bubble and
in boston
and milwaukee i am not as high on
milwaukee as others but
you know they're right there they're
right there with that group at the top
so
um i'm i'm i said two weeks ago the
sixers i'm not gonna jump
off that uh but certainly brooklyn ought
to be the favorite
ought to be richard i guess i don't i
don't i'm not a guy who checks vegas
but i know those numbers jumped when uh
that trade uh
was finalized to acquire james harden
michael wilbon
uh pardon the interruptions espn's uh
right here on the rich
show okay um let's move to football uh
who do you think wins it
from the final four who do you think
takes it home
michael well i certainly believe kansas
city will
you know if uh patrick mahomes is i
don't know
75 percent himself right i still and i
you know i i the one the only thing i
probably got right
um this season was thinking that buffalo
was the second best team in the afc
um i probably didn't get a lot of other
stuff right i
i don't in the nfc man it's how do you
how do you just
bet against tom brady the one thing i
think is working in green bay's
favorites the same thing that worked at
tampa's favor last week
i mean i you know i didn't think that
anybody was going to beat tom brady
three straight times i don't care how
good new orleans appeared to be
i was not taking new orleans to beat or
anybody to beat brady a third straight
time
so that is work that is what is working
the example this time even though it's
not two victories
it's the one the one the way they beat
the packers
when they beat them this year do i mean
who's who's whose care is gonna be on
fire more than aaron rodgers
coming off that loss remembering that
defeat
um and i it's it's bruce erie's job of
course tom brady will take some of that
on himself
to remind those guys that lap that that
victory meant nothing
just like it to me the failure of the
saints
as greater coach as sean payton is the
failure of the saints
was to understand that their two wins
meant nothing
and i don't know they couldn't convey
that they had a lot of casual plays
you know the tight ends fumble late in
the game where it looked like
uh the saints were gonna drive down and
and maybe take a 27-20 lead after the
game was tied to 20.
they didn't they didn't get that done
and i expect
the packers to understand that part so
if there's any edge
i'm i'm taking and again betting against
tom brady
is just the dumbest thing ever um but
i'm gonna
i'm gonna go narrowly and this is you
know child of the midwest
who hates the packers is historically an
institutional
as only a bear fan does i you know i've
had i've had
my life my football life made miserable
by people in green bay uniforms
so i'm i'm i understand that culture i'm
going with the packers
well michael i i this game is so uh
amazing and so um
rife with legacy talk um as we like to
do
um with brady and rogers that
that um for me i can't wait because the
narrative
for rogers that at age 37 his response
to the drafting of jordan love is just
to take a few
you know uh tugs on his uh on his
you know four fingers deep in a drink on
draft night and just
exhale and come up with his best season
and make it to the super bowl and win
the mvp
uh or tom brady to basically say okay
uh after 20 years uh i'm gonna go at age
43 to tampa
and make the super bowl with them and
make it
by going through brees and rogers
and then on top of it uh i'll be the
first quarterback to
play in all my home stadium in the super
bowl
and take care of mahomes too at age 43
and just put that on the table for
everybody
like that is that's in the ether right
now michael and i
and yeah and you can't yeah i i i that's
like that's the flame i'm the moth to
that flame for this game and
and beyond potentially here you know
yeah
it's sort of unthinkable considering
some of the losses that tampa had during
the season
um you know obviously the blowout was
the second blowout loss when it was
was that game at some point 35 nothing
the the yeah that sunday night game
it was yeah i think they kicked a field
goal just uh as a nice little fig leaf
michael in that game i believe right
right something three that's right
right so i mean that loss the loss where
brady's holding up the four fingers
and when the bears went to yeah five and
one or whatever i mean that that
there's some bet those are bad losses
those are unthinkable losses for a
championship team
i keep thinking that there's a little of
that in that team
like when you see that kind of i mean
look green bay has a bad loss they don't
have two
and and remember tampa got out played by
the giants on national television a
sunday or monday night or thursday night
or something
they got out played by the giants that
would have been
the most embarrassing of the of the
losses so part of me thinks you know
there's a little dog
in in tampa i don't know maybe they're
over it they won five straight now
they've won two
so i guess it's what six straight
they've won going into this game so
i i part of me still thinks okay there's
that
but man doesn't that get trumped by the
presence of tom brady
um i'm so i'm i'm going with the packers
but
you know i'm not going to vegas on that
one and
and patrick mahomes and this i mean
maybe the foot
is going to be something to worry about
more than the head
not the protocol part of it but just the
playing on sunday part of it
because mahomes mobility accepts up
everything he does
you know all that wizardry his movement
i don't mean
running obviously like lamar jackson but
it's movement
you need feet to move and so i still
have that image of him
you know needing a standing eight count
after that hit he he took so i we don't
know
you know the one thing that people went
crazy over
when predicting that you know kansas
city is going to win the next five super
bowls it's like stop that
it's just dumb because injuries in
this sport are the elephant in the room
and so we don't know how mahomes is
going to be you know for one more super
bowl
i hope he's i hope he's as close to
patrick mahomes as he can be so we can
see kansas city at that bastard
last one for you michael before i let
you go uh pace and naggy kept
what do you think about that for the uh
for for the bears what'd you think about
that
you know i'm i'm less troubled about it
with negan
um if he's figured out that he has to
coach the players he's got
as opposed to fantasizing about coaching
some of the players he left behind
kansas city
if he's finally gotten that then okay
let's let's tee it up one more time with
him i mean the general manager has
you know just sort of proven and he's
made some he's made some nice moves over
the time
um i mean trading for khalil max you
know drafting roquan smith
um drafting uh mooney the kid who
couldn't play the receiver he's
he's a nice player but this is a
quarterback league this is the national
league of quarterbacks and when you make
the mistake
that you made and then you you you make
another one
and trying to cover up the mistake you
made
and you bring in foals who can't play
you can't play anymore maybe you can
play with the green uniform on me ain't
playing any other uniform
i i got a bigger problem with him than i
have with neggie
and ultimately the problems with all
three of them the general manager the
coach the quarterback
when you're inadequate at those
positions rich you don't have a
franchise that's right
and there's no there's no debate anymore
there's no there's no debate about
maggie not wanting to coach mr bisky he
didn't want to coach him
he wanted to coach the guy he had his
red shirt here patrick mahomes
well then you should have stayed in
kansas city because the guy you got
ain't patrick mahomes
he needs to be coached differently and
by the way i'm not so sure that
mitch trubisky can't play playoff
football in the
in the nfl i'm not convinced that he's
not my homes
but you can win a championship without
my home because it's only been done in
the super bowl
52 other times or whatever it is right
so he's not the only quarterback
but you got to coach him and have a
system and have a plan
ready for him and that team and so i
i am skeptical about it i am
angry that i see the packers come out
there and blow their doors off every
time they play
and you know rogers is just laughing to
himself because he won't do that
publicly
he's not philip rivers he's not going to
just talk his whole way through every
game
but man it's hard to be a bears fan
right now and think that anything
special is going to come with the next
couple of years
unless there's a 180 degree turn around
where they make a big change
love you michael wilbon thanks for the
call appreciate it
appreciate it man good to hear your
voice right back at you that's michael
wilbon we'll see him on pardon the
interruption later on today on espn
one of the best tv shows in the history
of our sports medium and of course
you'll see him on espn
at real michael wilbon at real mike
wilbon on twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here